يقول الأوكرانيون إنهم
تمكنوا من ضرب
طائرتين روسيتين مهمتين للغاية لحملة موسكو الجوية
ضد هذا البلد، إحداهما
تسمى A50 barav وهي
نظام للإنذار المبكر والتحكم المحمول جواً، وبعبارة أخرى، طائرة
تختار الأهداف على  الأرض
وينسق قتال القوات الجوية الروسية
ضد تلك الأهداف الآن،
يقول الأوكرانيون إن طائرة A50
barav هذه قد دمرت، وقالوا أيضًا
إنهم تمكنوا من ضرب طائرة تسمى
il22 وهي في الأساس
مركز قيادة محمول جواً يستخدمه الروس
الآن  قال الأوكرانيون في الأصل
إن تلك الطائرة دمرت أيضًا،
ولكن ظهرت لاحقًا صورة تظهر على ما يبدو
أن ذيل الطائرة قد
تعرض لأضرار بالغة، ولكن يبدو أن الطائرة
تمكنت من الهبوط في مطار داخل
روسيا. وفي وقت لاحق، ظهر صوت
يبدو أنه يظهر
طائرة تابعة للقوات الجوية الروسية.  التي كانت ترافق هذه الطائرة
تطلب من أحد المطارات على الأرض منح
تلك الطائرة تصريحًا
للهبوط الاضطراري، فلنستمع
[تصفيق] [
موسيقى]
الأوكرانيون يقولون إن هذه
الضربات على هذه الطائرات حدثت في
بحر آزو وهو في الواقع بعيد جدًا
بعيدًا عن أي نوع من الأراضي التي تسيطر عليها أوكرانيا،
لم يذكر الأوكرانيون أيضًا
كيف تمكنوا بالضبط من ضرب
هذه الطائرات،
ولم يعلق الروس من جانبهم حتى الآن على
الأمر كور لين سي إن إن نيو أوكرانيا